hello everyone and welcome back to the
gold money asian rapid tournament
the preliminaries are over and we are
now in the knockout phase of the
tournament and the first match that
we're covering is magnus carlsen versus
a wesley so
and it's uh it's a pretty great one this
is the first game and it already started
with a bang
and we would be very happy if this was
the finals of the event but this is only
the
uh the quarterfinals uh so uh you know
we are we are in for a treat so without
further ado let's check it out and then
we're gonna
talk a little bit more about the
tournament as we usually do
so magnus with the white pieces opens
with c4 he goes for the english opening
with e5 by wesley knight to c3
knight to f6 and now knight to f3 we're
gonna have the four knights of the
english
uh we have a3 by magnus and now d5
striking in the center
uh we have captures captures and now
queen to c2
so already developing the queen with f5
by wesley
and now d3 and here there is one game in
the database where knight to f6 was
played
uh but here we have bishop to e7 and it
is now as of move seven that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
magnus continues here we have e3
uh bishop to e6 nicely continuing
development and the bishop to e2 magnus
does the same
we have castles castles both players
bring their king to safety and now
a5 preventing further expansion uh
on the queen side by from white by
playing some like b4 so rook
d1 uh and now king the h8 a nice
uh prophylactic move with the king later
on you don't have to worry about any
checks in coming your way
uh and if neither you can always tuck
this bishop back to g8
we have knight the a4 by magnus now
fighting for the c5 square
uh and wesley doesn't want to allow
knight to c5 so here
he just brings the queen queen to d6 now
grabbing hold of the d
uh c5 square uh and now as a5 has been
played you don't have to worry about b4
and the white
really grabbing that c5 square so bishop
to d2
and now comes g5 so wesley starts his
attack on the king side and now the king
has been put to h8 now you can bring the
rook even to g8 the other rook to f8 or
you know the depending on how white
plays and here uh the principle thing to
do when you're attacked on the king side
you want to counter attack on the
uh well mostly in the center of the
board so here magnus strikes in the
center with d4
uh we have e4 by wesley and now knight
that's not the knight knight to e5 and
this knight the e5 is a pawn sacrifice
and magnus does it in order to open up
this diagonal
but wesley still has his dark square
bishop so it's questionable how
well magnus will be able to use this
dark square diagonal so here at knight
capture spawn captures queen captures
wesley accepts the pawn
and now bishop to c4 already with a
terrible threat of bishop capture son
and the e5 just removing that defender
of the c3 square and if you allow this
then just capture the bishop grabs hold
of this diagonal could be
very very unpleasant for black so here
we have bishop to f6 now
countering this idea and now knight to
c5 now again putting pressure on this
bishop
so you can't grab the b2 pawn as the
bishop on e6 would be hanging so bishop
to g8 luckily wesley already played king
to h8
and now rook 8 to b1 uh stopping this
queen captures on b2 idea we have queen
back to e7 by wesley
and now knight captures on b7 magnus
grabs his pawn back
we have f4 by wesley west to continue
the attack on the king side and now
magnus needs to find a good continuation
b4 is a very nice continuation here as
you might have imagined
but magnus just ruthlessly grabs another
pawn
he creates a past a pawn and now uh his
position
seems to be great unless uh wesley finds
one move so feel free to pause the video
here
but not just yet first obviously played
f captures f captures and
now feel free to pause the video here so
it's a little bit easier and find
wesley's idea while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
only move that gives
wesley a winning edge and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it is of course rook captures an a5
that's why
capturing the a pawn wasn't uh the most
precise way to continue
now the point is uh if magnus accepts
this and plays bishop captures an a5
then we play knight captures an e3 with
an attack on the rook
queen and the bishop here and after the
queen moves we're gonna pick up the rook
here
captures captures and now queen to c5
check you lose the bishop
as well so there's that king h1 we're
going to capture here
and after captures and captures at the
end of this long variation we are up a
full piece and we have a completely
winning
winning game so instead after this rook
captures on a5 magnus decided to go
bishop captures on d5 first
uh and now wesley plays rook captures on
d5
now rook captures on d5 is a fine move
but there there is a much finer one
and i'm just going to show it to you
because it's uh well it's just uh
it would be it would be unfair to ask
you to find this but instead of
capturing here
uh the in between rook to c5 is the move
that wesley
should have played now with an attack on
the queen and now the queen has to move
so once the queen moves
let's say you play now a queen captures
on e4 now we capture here on d5 with the
bishop and now
uh you don't really have all that many
squares you can trade queens then
captures captures and now
west can simply enjoy his winning
advantage he is still up a piece and
it's not much of a problem winning this
however he played rook captures on d5
right away and now he keeps the queens
on the board and this allows magnus to
stir some trouble here bishop to b4
attacking the rook and the queen
and wesley now trades on d1 now although
you could play c5 c5 uh
even though yes you can just capture on
d5 and remove one of the defenders
is still the best way to go because
after we capture and bishop captures
you're going to capture
here but then queen c7 pins the bishop
so you you don't lose the rook on f8
so that was kind of the way to go b4
still gives a black counter
white counter play but it's uh it's a
better position for black of course
so instead after this bishop to b4
wesley played rook captures on d1 with
check rook captures and now c5
but now this makes it a bit easier for
magnus bishop captures on c5 we have
queen to c7 blocking
uh and now b4 but now uh with uh with a
pair of rooks
traded off the board it seems to be um
more favoring favoring magnets than it
actually does wesley so here we have
rook the e8 regarding the e4 pawn
now comes a4 magnus says all right i i
don't really have much to offer here i'm
down a piece i have to push my passport
and hope for the best
so here bishop to e5 wesley threatens
the h2 pawn
h3 and now g4 saying okay you either
capture or i'm gonna bust open your
uh king's defenses so uh we have h
captures on g4 and now queen to g7
preparing to capture back
so magnus plays bishop to d4 saying okay
if you capture then i can capture this
with
check and now we have bishop the e6
so what do you play here uh you could
also play queen capture uh
you could also play bishop captures on
d4 right away uh but then after rook
on b4 and let's say queen captures on g4
we continue pushing b5 and it's still
a piece up for black but it's a light
square bishop and this pawn is on a
light square so it kind of blocks this
diagonal that you really want to use for
attacking purposes so here the the two
pass pawns would be
uh more favorable than this uh or will
awkwardly placed bishop and g8
so instead after bishop to d4 we have
bishop to e6 wesley wants to
activate this bishop somehow magnus
plays queen to c6 now with pressure on
the bishop
and under rook here and now wesley
defends not by playing rook to e7 which
is the correct idea he play
he he defends by playing bishop to d7
but now it's magnus who's completely
winning so feel free to pause the video
here
and win the game for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always finding
new ways to sacrifice your queen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course queen
captures on d7
after magnus played this it was in this
position on move 33 that
wesley resigned the game as now there is
nothing more to be done here point is
if you accept to the queen then it's
just the bishop captures an e5 with
check and we win the queen back
with a with a far superior superior
position rook captures um
uh to eliminate check now rook captures
on d7 and
it's five points against two and two
connected pass pawns here on the queen
side this is completely unplayable
and aside from that after queen captures
on d7 you really don't have a a good
move because the rook is hanging there
there's just not much you can do
you can't defend the rook and keep an
eye on the bishop here so
if you move the queen to defend the rook
then you lose the bishop here
and there's really not all that much if
you play something like rook to e7
then queen to d8 and you're again
getting checkmated king queen to g8 now
we're gonna capture with the bishop here
with
check the queen can't move the king
can't move uh you can either block with
the rook or capture the bishop but it
doesn't matter rook captures an e5
just queen to f6 with czech king queen
to g7 and now rook to d8 with check and
once the rogue blocks we're just gonna
capture here with checkmate so uh wesley
really uh
uh giving magnus the win here he he uh
you know
had the upper hand he took advantage of
uh carlson's mistake he played the the
the correct rook captures an a5 idea uh
but he just didn't
continue in the best possible way and
that's of course not the way to defeat
the world champion
so here uh like i said magnus just
played queen capture 7 and
wesley resigned the game so really a
nice game
magnus starts off with a win and we'll
see what happens in this one as
wesley has proven to be a most uh
unpleasant opponent for magnus so we'll
see if he will be able to bounce back
and and
pose more problems because four games
are being played in in the match today
uh so there's plenty of chance for
wesley to bounce back
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
andre sandu david kimura nigel holloway
happy birthday gavin and leander
moderson for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the
uh knockout section of this tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day